ja willkommen zur aktuellen Vorlesung
ich habe noch ein paar neue Begriffe ins
begriffsnetz eingefügt
und zwar betreffend die den Begriff des
Wertes den Begriff des Wertes den habe
ich noch mal hingenommen zum Kontext von
Normativität
hier unten hier sieht man ihn
Normativität und wert
das ist immer die Frage was ein Wert hat
das ist das gilt etwas das ist nicht nur
etwas was existiert sind das ist etwas
was existieren soll deswegen habe ich
den jetzt noch den Begriff zu
Normativität genommen
natürlich Wert und sollen stehen im
Verhältnis und auch die Frage nach dem
Wert und der Natur
haben natürliche eigen natürliche Dinge
haben die auch einen Wert als natürliche
Dinge oder woher kommt der Wert
überhaupt
das Gute das Böse und so weiter über das
Böse soll es heute noch mal gehen ich
habe da noch moralischen Zurechenbarkeit
hier rein habe ich jetzt tendenziell
eher auf der Seite individuellen Person
wir werden aber auch noch ein bisschen
darüber diskutieren ob vielleicht nicht
kollektive auch zurechenbar sind und
hier habe ich noch die Absicht rein
die habe ich eher auf die Seite der
individuellen Person und das Joint
commitment habe ich ihr auf der Seite
das habe ich auch nur auf der Seite der
kollektiven Person ja man kann
sicherlich sagen kollektive Personen
wenn sie es überhaupt gibt haben
Absichten natürlich Unternehmen und
Universitäten machen was als Kollektiv
wie jetzt die Meinungsbildung zustande
kam wie die Absicht einer kollektiven
Person gebildet wurde ist auch ein
spannendes Thema zum Beispiel Abstimmung
und so weiter sofort komplett Willens
und Meinungsbildung man nennt das nennen
sich noch das ist die ist joint
commitment damit dieses diese
gemeinschaftlichtung auf was so würde
ich die Absicht von kollektiven Personen
bestimmen das wollte ich noch ergänzen
und jetzt möchte ich ein Wiederholung
geben ein Rückblick der aber eben keine
lose Wiederholung ist ja noch ein
bisschen Schritt weiter geht nämlich
möchte ich heute noch auf das Böse
eingehen das moralisch böse und eine
wichtige Unterscheidung einführen also
Moralität muss man sich anschauen das
ist das moralisch gute dass der
sittlichen Norm entsprechende Moralität
kann aber auch so verstanden werden dass
das einfach der Bereich dessen ist was
moralisch bewertet werden kann wir
bewegen uns hier nicht im moralischen
Kontext das betrifft nicht die Moralität
könnte man auch sagen zu etwas was
vielleicht böse ist das dann weitere
Begriff aber in der Regel wenn wir von
der Moralität von etwas sprechen meinen
wir das ist der südlichen Norm
entspricht und das ist das gute ist das
moralisch gut dann haben wir die
Moralität
das ist jetzt das moralisch böse wenn
wir so nennen wollen oder dass der
sittlichen Norm widersprechende das
unmoralische das ist die Immoralität und
dann gibt es aber noch eine dritte
Kategorie nämlich die Amoralität und die
würde ich so bestimmen das ist das
neutral die neutrale Handlung die
gegenüber der sittlichen Norm
indifferent ist da kann man verschiedene
Beispiele bringen wenn Sie zum Beispiel
ja sich irgendwie ein wenn Sie ein
McDonald's gehen und sich an Hamburger
bestellen wir kommen heute noch auf
dieses Beispiel deswegen wenig das dann
ist diese Bestellung des Hamburgers oder
bei Burger King oder wenn dies oder wo
Sie wollen ja gar keine Schleichwerbung
machen dann ist natürlich ein legaler
Bürger und Gesundheit und so weiter dann
ist diese Bestellung diese Handlung der
Bestellung ist dann
könnte man sagen eine Sache der
Indifferenz das ist nicht irgendwie
moralisch relevant ja man könnte sagen
Amoral nicht im häufig verwendet man
aber auch Amoral im Sinne der
Immoralität ja also der Begriff ist auch
nicht so ganz klar ich will damit mich
gar nicht jetzt am Wort aufhalten
sondern eher an dem was ich darunter
geschrieben habe also es gibt Handlungen
die sind moralisch gut zu nennen die
entsprechende sittlichen Norm hängt
natürlich immer davon ab ob es so eine
objektive sittliche Norm auch gibt und
ob die begründet werden kann das setzen
wir jetzt einfach mal voraus und
überlassen dass der anderen vorlesen und
dem anderen kernkus der es mit Ethik und
Moralphilosophie zu tun hat mit Moral
Begründung diese Aufgabe müssen wir uns
hier nicht stellen explizit dann haben
wir eben die Moralität dasjenige was sie
wirklich spricht das unmoralische ich
spreche gerne von bösen aber natürlich
immer an einem kritischen Sinne nicht in
einem die Familien sind in einem
qualifizierenden Sinne und die
Amoralität dasjenige was einfach sich
nicht anbietet moralisch gut oder
moralisch schlecht genannt zu werden
weil es einfach gar nicht qualifizierbar
ist es ist keine Handlung die irgendwie
überhaupt eine Menschen schaden möchte
und nutzen möchte sondern es geht
einfach um was alltägliches zum Beispiel
was wir einfach tun müssen ja genauso
guten Kuchen backen ich backe einen
Kuchen für mich
gut
wenn ich jetzt einen Kuchen backe der
mir schade dann ist es vielleicht könnte
man darüber diskutieren
wenn ich den Kuchen backen für eine
andere Person um mir zu helfen weil sie
nicht gut geht weil ich eine Absicht mit
habe könnte man sagen okay ist ein guter
wobei der Kuchen das müsste man sagen es
sind nicht nur Kuchen backen sondern das
Kuchen backen und das Verschenken des
Kuchen sehr ähm jedenfalls scheint
solche Handlung zu geben die weder
normales guten noch unmoralisch das
Bösen zu verstehen sind und darüber
wollen wir kurz jetzt diskutieren ob sie
das genauso sehen ja man kann treffen
wie bei allem in der Philosophie drüber
streiten ob es überhaupt hier diese
letzte Kategorie gibt Amoralität ich
möchte noch darauf hinweisen und
Vorgriff auf die letzte thematische
Sitzung der Vorlesung auf das Thema
Rationalität und auch da kann man diese
drei Unterscheidung bringen hier die
Moralität Rationalität dann wie
e-moralität Irrationalität das
unvernünftige hier würde zum Beispiel
darunter fallen Willens schwaches Handel
nach Donald Davidson und wir könnten
noch das Phänomen des amoralischen und
überlegen das was nicht gegen die
Vernunft ist sondern völlig unabhängig
von der vernünftigen gar keiner
Beziehung steht wo es ein
Kategorienfehler wäre eine Handlung als
rational oder rational anzusehen genau
dasselbe gilt natürlich für amoralische
Handlung wenn es sie gibt es wäre ein
Kategorienfehler von ihnen in einem
moralischen Hinsicht zu sprechen weil
sie einfach aufgrund ihrer Natur so sind
dass sie sich nicht moralisch oder
normativ bewerten lassen das ist auf
jeden Fall ganz wichtig diese diese
dritte Dimension noch mit ins Zentrum zu
stellen wir haben uns gefragt ist das
moralisch Böse das unmoralische kann man
immer jetzt hier gleich bedeuten
rational verständlich welche Gründe
sollten wir haben moralisch zu handeln
ist der Begriff des digitales bösen oder
das unmoralischen wirklich Grundbegriff
der praktischen Philosophie
wie hängt der Begriff des humoralischen
und das bösen mit anderen Grundbegriffen
der moralischen praktischen Philosophie
zusammen darum geht es geht also
nächstes hier ob sie jetzt glauben es
gibt das Böse in der Welt oder das
unmoralische darum geht es hier nicht
das geht nur darum wenn wir davon
ausgehen der Begriff ist sinnvoll welche
anderen Grundbegriffe müssen wir dann
auch noch mit ins Spiel bringen und wie
müssen Sie mir Sie mit diesem Begriff
des moralischen eine Verbindung setzen
und anders formuliert wenn wir davon
ausgehen der Begriff macht keinen Sinn
des Konzept ist sinnlos wir müssen uns
ebenso fragen wie wir denn dann uns
Intuition das was böse ist erklären
können wenn sie nur entscheidend
und wir müssen schauen wie die anderen
Grundbegriffe der praktischen
Philosophie dann neu ordnen ein
Verhältnis bringen hängt natürlich auch
mit dem Begriff der Freiheit unter
zurechtbarkeit Sam meine These
jedenfalls ist jetzt die das Böse sind
von der Grundbegriff
und ich glaube dass wir mit Hilfe eines
kritischen Begriffs des Bösen also nicht
mit einem naiven so der Teufel oder so
irgendwie dunkle mächt ist dann wirklich
Handlungen Motive die unmoralisch sind
dass wir da verschiedene andere
praktische Grundbegriffe besser
verstehen kann
wenn wir bestreiten dass die Begriff des
Bösen sinnvoll ist müssen wir die Gründe
für uns Intuitionen dass der nicht
sinnvoll ist explizieren genauso wie wir
natürlich wenn wir annehmen dass der
Begriff des Bösen sind voll ist unsere
Intuition für die Existenz für die
sinnvolle Existenz auch existenziell
müssen in jeder Hinsicht alles Gute
Philosoph finden Philosophen
Rechenschaft ablegen spricht Gründe gute
zwingende Gründe ich habe noch so eine
These Form des unmoralischen sind
philosophisch interessante als Formen
des moralisch guten
jetzt haben wir was losgelassen hier da
erwarte ich jetzt eine heftige
Diskussion unten im auf Youtube oder gar
nicht hier schüttelt man den Kopf und
jetzt mache ich noch eine allgemeine
these
Formen des negativen und Scheiterns wie
zum Beispiel der Irrtum oder auch das
ungeraden schon erlaubt ist uns
etablierte philosophische Begriffe wie
zum Beispiel den der Wahrheit aus einer
ganz anderen Perspektive kritisch zu
überdenken vielleicht auch gar nicht so
eine tolle these jetzt aber meine
Intuition die ich natürlich noch weitere
Gründen muss ist die manchmal ist es
interessanter nicht auf das Gelingen
hinzublicken Begriff der Wahrheit
Begriff des Guten Sie sich mal über die
anderen die Schatten Zeit die misslingen
Fälle diesen Phänomen zu nähern das kann
vielleicht manchmal ganz hilfreich sein
und jetzt möchte ich Ihnen auch noch im
Zuge der erweiterten Wiederholung mal
konkretes Praxisbeispiel machen hier wir
wollen immer konkret bleiben und zwar
fragen uns was macht den Hass moralisch
problematisch was ist überhaupt Hass
natürlich kann man jetzt darüber
diskutieren ob Hass überhaupt moralisch
problematisch ist
das wollen wir jetzt auch gleich tun
ich habe nämlich eine These Hass ist
nicht nur eine starke Emotion ich glaube
da sind wir uns alle einnehmen sondern
er ist eine innere Handlung die
moralisch problematisch ist sie möchte
jetzt erstmal kurz innehalten und wieder
ein bisschen zu diskutieren und dann
möchte das näher ausführen ja wir haben
über den Hass geredet den wir oder den
ich zumindest als eine Form des
unmoralischen betrachten würde warum ist
er problematisch natürlich ist er eine
Emotion ist eine ganz starke Emotion ich
vertreten Sie dieses innere Handlung
also wir tun was im Harz was tun wir
müssen uns jetzt hier konkrete Beispiel
überlegen und argumentieren und den
Begriff klären so soll es ja auch in der
Philosophie immer sein und jetzt
entwickeln wir mal eine Phänomenologie
des Hasses so nennt man das was wir
jetzt hier gerade getan haben
verschiedene
Kontexte zu betrachten in denen dieses
Phänomen das ist ein Phänomen auftritt
und es möglichst genau zu beschreiben
ohne Vorankommen das nennt man
Phänomenologie wir sprechen so vom Hass
dass er wie ein Feuer in uns brennt oder
lodert und in jemanden häufig sagen wir
das nicht über uns über andere als
Zeugnis ist der Hass eine sehr starke
Emotion die ein motivationaler Grund für
eine aggressive Handlung sein kann und
sich wie eine Kraft gegen das Opfer
grausam unerbittlich und blind entladen
kann das ist eine aufgestaute Energie
allerdings und es ist mir jetzt wichtig
entsteht der Hass in uns nicht einfach
so und plötzlich sondern er wird durch
radikalisierende Gründe wie ein Feuer
genährt und angefacht wir müssen den
Hass in uns am Brennen erhalten wenn wir
da nicht weitere radikalisierende
Luftstöße hinzugeben Sauerstoff oder
noch ein Pilzchen ins Feuer des Hauses
ein noch ein scheiß ins Feuer des Hasses
geben dann erlischt der wir müssen uns
radikalisieren darin
sonst geht der letztendlich aus der
erstens eine Stadt dieses näheren und
einfachen des Hasses durch das
zurechtlegen von scheinbar guten Gründen
und damit erfolgen die innere
Radikalisierung und Rechtfertigung wie
können wir als eine innere Handlung
ansehen also ich will damit nur zu
Beginn geben häufig erweisen sich
Phänomene die auf den ersten Blick als
bloße dumm für Emotionen erscheinen wie
z.B der hat als Strukturen die man im
Sinne von Handlung deuten und auch
moralisch zu rechnen kann ja das ist
eine ganz wichtig und wir haben ja noch
ein wichtiges Phänomen kennengelernt
hast radikalisiert hast
simplifiziert und Objektiv wird auch
häufig die Person der gegenüber sie
empfunden wird man konzentriert sich auf
die man schließt sich auf sie ein und
man interpretiert die gesamte Person nur
unter dieser emotionalen Einstellung und
sieht vielleicht gar nicht andere
positiv Webseiten also man reduziert die
Person auch irgendwie ich glaube auch
dass man sie objektiviert und zum
Gegenstand macht und auch deshalb ich
für moralisch problematisch und jetzt
kann man eben diese innere Handlung des
Hauses wenn man zu dem moralisch
kritisieren weil sie radikalisieren und
unkritisch selbst improvisieren selbst
täuschend geschieht was dann häufig eine
äußere Handlung zur Folge hat die
äußerst brutales weil hast dann als
motivationaler guter Grund gelten kann
für die Handlung die wir ansonsten nicht
helfen da musste hast als motivationale
Basis im Hintergrund gestanden haben
interpretieren jetzt habe ich schon mal
den hast hervorgeholt den Thomas gleich
wieder löschen wir entziehen ihm allen
Sauerstoff alles drin Material und
schauen uns mal eine ganze Liste von
Form des unmoralischen an ich bringe das
deswegen weil ich gerade ein Handbuch
Immoralität im Planung habe also sowas
soll es auch geben na da kann man sich
also von mir natürlich nur aus
theoretischen Interesse soll keine
Anleitung sein
Hass Eifersucht nein nein Eifersucht
kein Praxishandbuch sondern nur ein
theoretisches Handbuch kein Workshop das
gibt es leider nicht leid dann noch
Rache dann noch Schadenfreude dann noch
Zorn ist auch so ein Punkt wobei da kann
man schon eher gerechtfertigt sein im
Zorn aber auch der hat eine Form von
Unbeherrschtheit so ne jetzt gibt es
natürlich noch weitere Kategorien wir
können auch noch Haltungen und
Einstellungen unterscheiden wobei man
hier auch immer treffen streiten kann ob
jetzt das einen diese Kategorie oder
diese Karte gehört Arroganz ist
sicherlich eine Einstellung und der
Haltung Egoismus
Gehässigkeit Heuchelei
Hochmut
Schamlosigkeit und zum Schluss noch
Handlungen und Strategien
Entmenschlichung
Erpressung Polter Psychoterror
Tierquälerei Verleumdung und die
Vermehrung also sie sehen es gibt ein
ganzes Arsenal von Form des
unmoralischen mit denen ich sie jetzt
hier aber nicht länger behelligen möchte
und natürlich auch die Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer nicht das Handbuch soll
wenn es gut geht Ende des Jahres
erscheint und jetzt komme ich noch mal
auf moralisches Verantwortung und zu
welchen barkeit zu sprechen
und da scheint mir was ganz wichtig zu
sein wir sprechen dann von Verantwortung
oder moralische zubrechenbarkeit
wenn es um moralisch problematische
Ereignisse geht ja wir fragen wer trägt
Schuld an etwas wenn wir nach
moralischer Verantwortung Fragen oder
nach zurrechenbarkeit ja ich gebe ihnen
Beispiel immer gut Beispiele zu bringen
wir würden uns wundern und lachen wenn
wir in einem Restaurant wenn jemand
aufstehenden Restaurant mit lauter
erregt der Stimme fragt wer ist für das
Essen verantwortlich und dann sagt das
Essen ist hervorragend das würden sie
als
seltsam wenn ich da ironisch wahrnehme
warum weil man eben
in der Regel
voraussetzt dass etwas der Name spricht
normales und dass ich da die zu
rechnungsfrage gar nicht stellt was man
natürlich wieder kritisieren kann
vielleicht sollte man auch viel häufiger
loben ja einfach jemanden dafür dass Sie
was gut getan hat es ist eigentlich
vielleicht sogar schlimm dass wir so
eine Situation als ironisch verstehen
vielleicht kann man das häufiger tun und
weil das so eine philosophische Frage
ist sage ich ihnen ich hoffe es klappt
jetzt ein interessantes Video und das
heißt eben dass das moralische Problem
der Zurechenbarkeit auch die Frage nach
Willensfreiheit nach kompatibilismus und
libertarianismus und Determinismus
betrifft und jetzt gibt es ein Problem
für Fortgeschrittene das wird natürlich
jetzt nicht in der Klausur ankommen wie
können wir moralische Zurechenbarkeit
auf Basis von
kompatibilismus von libertavianismus
oder sogar von Determinismus begründet
ja es ist eine ganz spannende
Herausforderung das kann man vielleicht
beim Tutorium machen aber es ist etwas
also sie müssen sich praktisch erst
fragen ähm was ist überhaupt noch mal
kompatibilismus ja das ist natürlich
eine Frage des Typs ah der Klausmann
genauso was ist ja
klare Frage Typ A die terminismus auch
also was was wird da noch mal
vorausgesetzt und dann müssen wir fragen
wie können wir im Rahmen dieser Theorie
wie können wir da bitteschön sowas wie
moralische Zurechenbarkeit moralische
Verantwortung das also eine Handlung auf
eine Person ursächlich zurückverfolgt
werden kann wie können wir das erklären
da können Sie sich überlegen da gibt es
eine riesen Debatte drin ja in welchem
Setting können wir moralische zu
sprechenbarkeit am besten erklären
natürlich ist immer leicht zu sagen
moralische zurechtbarkeit gibt's gar
nicht weil
eben der hatte der Termin ist die
einfachste Antwort ja das wird ziemlich
tricky wenn sie mal versuchen das z.B
von einer kompatibilistischen Position
heraus zu erklären alles ist der
terminiert durch Naturgesetz trotzdem
sind wir frei und natürlich auch
verantwortlich dafür
aber das ist es eine Übung sowas kommt
auch nicht in der Klausur vor das ist zu
anspruchsvoll aber wenn sie sich mal die
Mühe machen wollen können Sie darüber
mal diskutieren das Konsequenz Argument
habe ich ihn schon gezeigt dass es von
Peter Vanille also der wenn der
terminismus war ist dann sind alle
unsere Handlungen bloße Konsequenzen von
vergangenen Zuständen in Verbindung mit
dem Naturgesetzen und die wiederum sind
natürlich die Zustände sind natürlich
bedingt durch vorherige Zustände vor
unserer Geburt lagen so dass eigentlich
gar nicht wir hatten wir was tun sonst
Zustände sich durch uns praktisch
hindurch kausal bemerkbar machen die
aber schon vor unsere Geburt in Gang
gesetzt worden waren vielleicht letzten
Endes durch den Urknall und dann kann
man vielleicht sagen der Urknall ist
Schuld ja aber das macht dann keinen
Sinn mehr zu sagen der Urknall ist
schuld an meiner unmoralischen Hand
dann möchte ich Sie noch einmal daran
erinnern und das ist sicherlich auch in
Vorbereitung auf vielleicht nicht
unbedingt jetzt unsere Klausur aber
mögliche Hausarbeiten oder sonstige
Klausuren sehr hilfreich die Stanford
and sei globide da gibt es nämlich einen
eigenen Artikel skept das ist immer baut
more responsibility und das hier ist nur
der einleitende Teil wenn sich das
gesamte Inhaltsverzeichnis anschauen
sehen Sie es gibt drei Punkte und davon
gibt es einen Punkt der ist der Punkt 2
Punkt 3 da geht's um die impossibility
ultimated responsibility und da denken
sie natürlich sofort an einen
Philosophen der diesen diese Position
vertreten hatte nämlich geilen Strauß
sein Aufsatz von 1994 wir haben uns
diese verschiedenen argumentspunkte
angeschaut auf
Ilias finden Sie den gesamten Aufsatz
weil sie sich näher anschauen wollen und
wir können darüber noch diskutieren ich
bringe hier noch meine kurz Version von
diesem Argument er sagt erstens nothing
can becausasui also Grund seiner
selbstursache selbst was sind kann die
course of itself zweitens and order to
beach spons actions have to be causer
Zoey at least insurgen crusion mental
respects er sagt ja körperlich es ist
nicht so entscheidend es geht um das
mentale Handlungen sozusagen und die
Konklusion sehr von nothing can
beachleben
weil wir eben nicht Ursache unserer
selbst sein können diesen ganz ganz
kurzes aber potentiertes Argument so
kann man natürlich auch über
argumentieren indem man eben eine
Prämisse noch eine Prämisse einfügt die
einführt die irgendwie einleuchtend ist
ja und dann eben die Konsequenzen
expliziert die aus diesem häufig
einleuchtenden
folgen so damit sie jetzt auch ein
bisschen aktiviert werden machen wir
jetzt hier mal wieder eine empirische
Studie das Ergebnis ist ziemlich
eindeutig fast 80 Prozent von ihnen
sagen ja moralische Verantwortung ist
möglich jetzt muss ich mich noch mal
dann wie war die haben eine Abstimmung
gemacht über Willensfreiheit weiß ich
gar nicht könnt mir vorstellen dass bei
Willensfreiheit weniger die Auffassung
vertreten hatten also es könnte sein
dass mehr der Auffassung sind dass wir
moralisch zurechenbar sind obwohl
praktisch nicht so viele der Auffassung
sind
und es ist nicht so ganz klar wie
verhalten sich Willensfreiheit und
moralische zurechtigkeit zueinander ja
darüber kann man auch wirklich ganz
interessante philosophische Überlegungen
anstellen
darauf möchte ich noch hinweisen
moralische Verantwortung steht immer im
Kontext von anderen Begriffen darum geht
es mir wirklich in dieser Vorlesung wenn
man da Auffassung ist wie 80 Prozent von
ihnen jetzt gerade der Begriff der
moralischen Zurechenbarkeit oder meint
wegen Verantwortung sinnvoller Begriff
der spiegelt was wieder in der Welt das
ist nicht nur so ein Konstrukt dann muss
man sich überlegen welche anderen
Begriffe aus unseren begriffsnetz wird
damit noch ins Feld führen müssen als
sinnvoll sicherlich die Person
individuell man kann sich jetzt fragen
ob auch kollektive Personen etwas
verantwortlich sein können wir haben
darüber in einer der ersten Sitzung
gesprochen immer oben Youtube Video den
Link rein zu dieser Sitzung können
kollektive Personen verantwortlich sein
für etwas ja denken Sie daran wenn zum
Beispiel große Firmen irgendetwas tun
was nicht ganz okay ist wenn man hier in
den Bodensee immer wieder alle Abwässer
rein lässt um sich die Entsorgung zu
sparen und das macht ein Unternehmen
kollektive Person vielleicht sogar die
Universität Konstanz würde sowas tun
alles ungefiltert in den Bodensee
ablassen dann würde sie zur
Verantwortung gezogen natürlich würden
dann irgendwelche individuellen Personen
am Ende auch dafür würden müssen aber
die Universität könnte vielleicht auch
eine Strafe aufgepumpt bekommen ich will
jetzt hier gar nicht weiter fantasieren
aber wir sehen auch diese Rede von
kollektiven Personen die für etwas
verantwortlich sind ist nicht so ganz
trivial also es kann man schon auch
sagen auf Seite der individuellen Person
steht ein Wille eine klare Achse
aufzeiten der kollektiven Person sowas
könnte sowas stehen wie ein Joint
commitment ja dass ich einfach hier die
leitenden Personen von einer kollektiven
Person auf eine transparente Art und
Weise auf etwas geeinigt haben eine
kollektive Willensbildung verzogen haben
nämlich alle Absätze in den Bodensee zu
lassen damit sie natürlich wieder bei
einer Form sich
unordenfreiheit scheint vor umgesetzt
werden zu müssen Autonomie vielleicht
stärkeren Sinne grundgründe müssen eine
Rolle mitgespielt haben man tut ja nicht
einfach so willkürlich alle Abwässer in
den Bodensee ableiten sondern das sind
Gründe mit im Spiel ob das jetzt gute
Gründe sind das ist eine andere Frage
aber motivationale Gründe müssen im
Spiel sein sonst hätte man sie nicht
gemacht es sei denn hier werden aus
Versehen alle Klärwerk übergelaufen und
durch Zufall wären diese abwesenden aber
das wäre wieder keine Handlung es könnte
höchstens Unterlassung gewesen sein
weitere wichtige Begriff Handeln und
Unterlassen dass man unterlassen hat
irgendwie die Kanalisation zu richten
und durch gewitterartige Niederschläge
dann alles zum Überlaufen gebracht wurde
natürlich wäre man daran auch schuld
weil man ja ist unterlassen hat das zu
vermeiden also Gründe Normativität diese
Handlung oder unterlassen wird bewertet
anhand von Objektiv geltenden zumindest
ist das Implikation
ja Regel eine Handlung haben wir schon
gesagt man könnte natürlich auch noch
Unterlassung daneben setzen die Handlung
kann gut oder böse sag mal lieber
unmoralisch ob es böse ist den Bodensee
zu verschmutzen ist eine andere Frage
hängt vielleicht davon ab was für den
Bodensee einlassen ja das eine könnte
nur unmoralisch sein das andere
vielleicht sogar böse wird sie gar nicht
weiter fantasieren
zurechtbarkeit ist auf jeden Fall der
letzte Begriff dann hier unten daran
hängt dann da wird dann die Schuld oder
der Verdienst zugesprochen eine
individuellen oder konnektiven Person ja
wo wir jetzt schon dabei sind über
Irrationalität auch gesprochen zu haben
gebe ich jetzt zum Schluss unsere
heutigen Vorlesung ein Ausblick auf die
nächste Folge und Sitzung die wird die
Frage behandeln welche Rolle
Selbsttäuschung für unsere Handeln
spielt
wichtigeres Thema Selbsttäuschung ich
glaube dass es wenn ich schon so fragt
das ist eine ganz zentrale Rolle ist die
Selbsttäuschung spielt und da muss man
wieder eine weitere Frage in den Blick
nehmen die nämlich wie verhalten sich
Gründe und Selbsttäuschung so einander
also Gründe und Selbsttäuschung fallen
sich ja erstmal wieder zu widersprechen
gute Gründe können ja nicht sein was
irgendwie mit Selbsttäuschung
zusammenhängt aber wie Beispiel des
neidisch gesehen haben gerade dann wenn
wir uns selbst täuschen führen wir über
Gründe an und rechtfertigen uns und
irgendwie ist es ein Problem dieses
Verhältnis man kann das noch genereller
jetzt fassen und fragen wie verhalten
sich Rationalität und Irrationalität
zueinander
natürlich kann man auch noch wie wir
heute am Beispiel der Moralität gesehen
haben der dritte Kategorie dazu nehmen
und es ist dann die Rationalität ja also
wir wollen uns Fragen gibt es sowas wie
ar Qualität überhaupt
wenn ja auch oder wir gute Gründe haben
dann müssen wir natürlich wie immer
Beispiele bringen rationales Handeln
könnte nämlich auch geneigt sein zu
sagen ja was irrational ist kann gar
keine Handlung sein Handlung setzt immer
schon irgendwie eine Form von
Rationalität voraus oder vielleicht noch
allgemeiner gesagt eine gewisse
Verbindung eine gewisse Beziehung auf
rationale Standards selbst dann wenn wir
in der Hand und die rationalen Standards
verletzen haben wir ja immer noch einen
Bezug zu Rationalität unterlaufen die
Rationalität indem wir eben zum Beispiel
irrational handeln Stichwort
Willensschwäche aber das muss man auch
genau erklären das scheint eine ganz
wichtig zu sein und diese Frage scheint
mir viel zu häufig nicht berücksichtigen
zu werden wenn es um praktische
Philosophie und das handelt geht und
dann kann man sich natürlich auch fragen
inwiefern können wir uns aus Freiheit
selbst täuschen wenn wir unmoralisch
handeln
glauben wir in den seltensten Fällen
dass wir unmoralisch Handeln wer tut
denn schon willentlich das Böse die
allerwenigsten würden von sich sagen ich
tue das weil es böse ist sondern wenn
Sie jemanden bei frischer Tat ertappen
wird er oder sie sagen wenn es wirklich
unmoralisch ist
nö ich tu doch eigentlich das Gute und
er oder sie wird in eine große
Geschichte erzählen in der vernünftige
Gründe aus seiner oder ihre Perspektive
jedenfalls eine Rolle spielen er oder
sie wird sich rechtfertigen und wird
sich versuchen zu verteidigen und zu
entschuldigen wenn Sie jemanden da zur
Verantwortung ziehen oder beschuldigen
einer Sache vielleicht sogar zu Recht
wird er oder sie in der Regel sich
verteidigen und Ausflüchte bringen die
aber immer die Form von Rechtfertigungen
haben und da werden Gründe angeführt und
wenn man jetzt aber dann am Ende zum
Ergebnis kommt er oder sie hat wirklich
unmoralisch gehandelt das kann man ihm
nachweisen dann muss man doch zugeben
kommen wenn die Person wirklich zur
Verantwortung zu ziehen ist für diese
unmoralische Handlung dass er oder sie
aus Freiheit diese Handlung getan hat
nicht willentlich und wissentlich direkt
daraus würden aber folgen dass die
Person sich doch irgendwie aus Freiheit
selbst getäuscht hat also die Frage
stellt sich praktisch inwiefern sind wir
für unsere Selbsttäuschung beantworten
das ist eine spannende Frage